turenne audu et j'ai une pierre dans le
ventre parce que je trouvais frappant on
commence à parler du film c'est que
c'est de constater qu'aujourd'hui encore
ce vide entre le peuple et le pouvoir
demeure
[Musique]
cet espace béant entre le peuple et
c'est lui qui est censé incarner son
intérêt qui fait aujourd'hui tous les
périls qui sont devant nous quoi qu'est
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir
l'ambiguïté surtout du peuple français
par rapport à ce désir va voir quand
même une grande figure sacralisé qui
représente la nation
bon ça s'est déporté sur sur le
président a un public qui vit dans un
palais l'elysée par palais
est ce que c'est ce que c'est plus sain
que qu'une forme de monarchie
parlementaire où constitutionnel ou une
monarchie anglaise je sais pas ce qu'il
ya de mieux moi je me pose je pose la
question quoi quand on est en fait
toujours en situations de déquilibre
plus ou moins fragile et que on peut
basculer d'un côté ou de l'autre très
très facilement et que tout ce qui est
tout ce qui a été construit pendant la
révolution française tout ce qui est
tout ce qui est décrite dans le film
tout ce qui est montré dans le film
c'est fragile pour qu'on soit tout le
temps en train d'essayer d'améliorer les
choses et de ne pas s'installer dans un
système et d'arrêter de le questionner
la vérité moi je pense c'est que c'est
que c'est ce que montre le film la
justice c'est physique
donc c'est un sentiment qu'on a on
ressent physiquement et émotionnellement
ce qui est juste pas juste on le sait on
le sait intrinsèquement donc on pourra
nous dire ce qu'on voudra je dire tant
que la justice sera pas plus grande et
plus forte
il y aura deux grandes raisons de se
soulever de se révolter et de
s'interroger ensemble